what role did the ideas of the founding
documents of this country play in this
war the war between the union and the
Confederate States
and the founding ideas that were
supposed to be unifying to this country
is there is there interesting tensions
there well there were certainly tensions
because built into the founding
documents of course is slavery and
inequality and women's exclusion from
voting and things of that sort uh but
the real Brilliance of Abraham Lincoln
is to build on the Brilliance of the
founders and turn the union position
into this into the defense of the core
ideas of the country so the Confederacy
is defending one idea the idea of
slavery
Lincoln takes the basket of all the
deeper ideas and puts them together
three things the war is about for
Lincoln and this is why his speeches
still resonate with us today you know
every time I'm in Washington I go to the
Lincoln Memorial
it's the best Memorial best Monument I
think in the world actually and
um there are always people there
reading Gettysburg address and the
second inaugural Lincoln had two years
of education yet he found the words to
describe what our country was about
better than anyone and it's because he
went back to these founding values three
values we already talked about one
freedom
that uh and freedom is is actually
complex but it's also simple
uh the simple Lincoln definition is that
freedom is the right of each person to
work for himself
or herself which is to say it doesn't
mean you own your own company it means
you control your labor
and no one can tell you you have to work
for a certain wage
you might not have a job but you decide
you decide right you can see where that
comes from his own background as a poor
man right so freedom is control of your
own labor
second democracy government of the
People by the people for the people the
government is to serve the peoples to
come from the people
and then the third Point Justice and
helping all human beings
he at the end of his life as the Civil
War is ending he never declares that the
South should be punished his argument is
that we shouldn't apologize for their
misdeeds
but that all should be part of this
future he's not arguing for consensus
he's arguing for a society where
everyone has a stake going forward
so Justice democracy Freedom those are
those those are the gifts I talked about
the flaws in our system those are the
the virtues in our system that our
Founders coming out of the Enlightenment
planted and and Lincoln carries them
forward he gives us the 2.0 version of
them so a few tangent questions about
each of those so one on democracy
people often bring up the United States
as a democracy it's a republic
um that it's representative is there
some interesting tensions there in
terminology or is
um yeah can you maybe kind of expand on
the different versions of democracy
um so the philosophy of democracy but
also the Practical implementations of it
sure the founders intended for us to be
a democracy this argument that they want
us to be a republican sort of a
democracy is one of these made up myths
they believed that fundamentally what
they were creating was a society very
few of which had existed before a
society where the government would be of
the People by the people for the people
that's what they expected right that's
what I meant so the legitimacy of our
government was not going to be that the
person in charge was of Royal Blood
that's the way the Europeans did it or
did the person in charge had killed
enough people Allah gang is gone or that
the person in charge uh was serving a
particular class it was that the person
in charge the institutions were to serve
of the people they adopted Republican
tools to get there
because they were fearful appropriately
of Simply throwing every issue up to the
masses democracy is not mob rule
democracy is where you create procedures
to assess the public will
and to act in ways that serve the public
without harming other elements of the
public that are not in the majority
that's why we have a constitution and a
Bill of Rights and at that for their
time the founders did not believe that
women should be part of this discussion
that they were not capable they were
wrong about that in their time that's
how they thought we've of course changed
that they believed you had to have
property to have a stake we don't
believe that anymore so we can argue
over the details and and those 50 years
from now will criticize us right for the
way we think about these things but it
was fundamentally about this is the
radicalism of the American experiment
that government should Serve the People
for all people so democracy means of the
People by the people for the people and
then it doesn't actually
give any details of how you implement
that because you could Implement all
kinds of voice and I think what we've
learned as historians I think what the
founders knew because they were very
well read in the history of Rome and
Greece was that democracy will always
have unique characteristics for the
culture that it's in
um if coming out of the war against
Russia Ukraine is able to build a better
democracy than it had before it's never
going to look like the United States
is I'm not saying it's gonna be worse or
better a culture matters the particular
history of societies uh matters uh Japan
is a vibrant democracy I've been there
many times uh it it does not look at all
like the American democracy so so
democracy is a set of values the
implementation of those values is a set
of practical institutional decisions one
makes based in one's cultural position
so just the wing on that topic is there
if you do representative you said like
you know democracy should not one
failure mode is Mob rule
so you should not descend into that not
every issue should be up to everybody
correct okay so you have a
representation but you know uh
Stalin
similarly felt that he could represent
the interests of the public he was also
helping represent the interests of the
public so that's a failure mode too the
if if the people representing the public
become more and more powerful they start
becoming detached from uh from actually
being able to represent or having just a
basic human sense of what the public
wants I I think being of the People by
the people for the people means you are
in some way accountable to the people
and the problem with the Communist Party
of the Soviet Union this was already
evident before Stalin came into power is
the same problem the Communist Party of
China has today which is that you have
leadership that's non-accountable
well let me go then to one of the other
three principles of freedom because one
of the ways to keep government
accountable is the freedom of the press
so there's a the internet and on the
internet there's social networks and one
of them is called Twitter I think you
have an account there people should
follow you and uh you know recently
people have been throwing around
recently for a while the words of
freedom of speech uh just out of
curiosity uh for tangent upon a tangent
uh what do you think of freedom of
speech as it is today and as it was at
that time during the Civil War after the
Civil War and throughout the history of
of America so freedom of speech has
always been one of the core tenets of
American democracy and I'm near
absolutist on it uh because I I think
that people should have the right to
speak uh what what makes our democracy
function is that there is always room
for quite frankly people like you and me
who uh like to disagree and have reasons
to disagree so I am against almost all
forms of censorship the only time I
believe in censorship is if somehow an
individual or a new newspaper has stolen
the Ukrainian plans for their next
military movements in the next week you
should not be able to publish that right
now maybe after they act but criticism
opinion interpretation should be wide
open now that doesn't mean though that
um you have the right to come to my
classroom and start shouting and saying
whatever you want yeah you have the
right on the street corner to do that
but my classroom is a classroom for my
students with a particular purpose sorry
about that from last week I'll never do
it again
I'm really sorry it's okay it never
happened you know we get drunk so the
people who don't know your your
professor UT Austin is just it's nearby
so sometimes I I get a little drunk and
wander in there I'm not the only one is
that you I didn't even know it was you
okay
um so the point is that free speech is
not licensed to invade someone else's
space and and I also believe in private
Enterprise so I think that um
you know if if if I owned a social media
Network I don't
it would be up to me to decide
who gets to speak on that Network and
who doesn't and then people could decide
not to use it if they don't want to use
it but there's uh so yes that's one of
the founding principles so oftentimes
when you talk about censorship that's
government uh censorship so a social
media if you run a social media company
you should be able to decide from a
technical perspective of what freedom of
speech means but there's some deeper
ethical philosophical
sense of
how do you create a world where
every voice is heard of the People by
the people for the people that's not a
that's a complicated technical problem
when you have a Public Square how do you
have a productive conversation where
critics aren't silenced but the same
time Whoever has the bigger megaphone is
not going to crowd out everybody else so
I think it's very important to uh create
rules of the game that'll give everyone
a chance to get started and that
um allow for guideposts to be created
from the will of the community which is
to say that we as a community can say We
Can't Stop people from speaking but we
as a community can say that in certain
forms we're going to create certain
rules
for who gets to speak and who doesn't
under what terms but they can still have
somewhere else to go so I'm I believe in
Opening space for everyone but creating
certain spaces within those spaces that
are designed for certain purposes that's
what a school does so I will not bring
someone to speak to my students who is
unqualified it's not a political
judgment the rules at a university are
where an educational institution you
need to have the educational credentials
to come speak about artificial
intelligence I'm not going to bring some
bum off the street to do that right we
have certain rules but that bomb on the
street can still in his own space or her
own space can still say what he or she
wants to say about artificial
intelligence this is how newspapers work
when I write for the New York Times They
have an editorial team the editorial
team makes certain decisions they check
facts and there's certain points of view
they don't allow anti-submitted comments
right you're not going to be able to
publish an anti-semitic screed whether
you think it's true or not true in the
New York Times but that doesn't prevent
you from finding somewhere else so we
allow entities to create certain rules
of the game we trans we make transparent
what those rules are and then we as
Citizens know where to go to get our
information what's what's been a problem
the last few decades I think is it
hasn't been clear what the rules are in
different places and what are the
legitimate places to get information and
what are not yeah the transparency seems
to be very critical there even from the
New York Times I think there's a lot of
skepticism about which way the editorial
processes lean I mean there's a public
perception that it's especially for
opinions it's going to be very
left-leaning in the New York Times and
without transparency
about what the process is like about the
people involved you all you do like
conspiracy theories and and the general
public opinion about that is going to go
go wild
and uh I think that's okay for the New
York Times people can in a collective
way figure stuff out like they could say
okay New York Times uh 73 of the time is
gonna lean left in their head they have
like a loose estimation or whatever uh
but for a platform like Twitter it seems
like they're it's more complicated now
of course there should be rules of the
game but I think there's a
maybe I want to say a responsibility to
also create incentives for people to do
High effort empathetic debate
versus throwing poop at each other yeah
I think those are two slightly different
things so I agree
I think that my view is that the failure
of Facebook and Twitter and others and
in recent years has been that they have
been completely untransparent about
their rules so what I would think would
make would Advance us
is if they had a set of rules that were
clear that were consistently followed
and we understood what they were
that would also tell us as consumers
how much what the biases are how to
understand what's going on it seems like
I might say that since Elon Musk has
taken over Twitter it's been arbitrary
and who's thrown off and who's not
thrown off who's and that's that's a
real problem arbitrariness is in some
ways the opposite of democracy but
there's also a hidden arbitrariness
in uh
interpretation of the rules so for
example
what comment incites violence
that's really really difficult to figure
out to be like there's a gray area
obviously there's very clear versions of
that but if I know anything about people
that try to incite violence they're
usually not coming out and clearly
saying it they're usually kind of dog
whistling it and same with racism and
anti-Semitism all of that it's usually
dog whistles so like and they usually
I have fun playing with the rules
playing around the rules so it's a it's
a gray area same with uh June covid
misinformation what's misinformation
right I agree and some of these are
age-old problems our legal system common
law has been struggling with what is
incitement to violence since the first
Supreme Court decisions in the 18th
century right so so you're absolutely
right but I will say this there are
certain things that are clearly
incitement to violence I'll give you
very clear examples uh I'll just make it
personal right my wife is an elected
official here in Austin there have been
people who have put things up on Twitter
calling for her to be hanged or calling
for her to be attacked that's incitement
of violence when you specifically call
for violence against someone I agree
there's a lot of other stuff where it's
a gray area but we could start
if we're applying these rules
yes by getting that material off of
these sites so some of that is a problem
of scale too but the gray area is still
a forever problem that we may never be
able to solve and maybe the tension
within the gray area is the very process
of democracy but saying like we need to
take our country back
is that a statement of violence I don't
think that I think we need to take our
country back just that no
but then you know because I might say
that I might say we need to take I say
that all the time I go again I walk
around drunk just screaming at everybody
I know you wanted it wants to take you
back exactly I was very confused and my
messaging needs to work but let's let's
go to the January 6th example right to
say hang Mike Pence that's incitement of
violence yeah to say go get Nancy
that's incitement to violence yeah yeah
it's very clear I again I don't think
that's the big problem the big problem
is the gray area but yet
uh and the other problem is just how to
get how to technically find the large
scale of comments and posts and so on
that are doing this kind of clearance
I mean don't ask me those questions well
I have to say some of that is motivation
some of that is vision and some of that
is execution so for example just to go
out briefly on a dark topic
um something I've recently became aware
of is yeah
Facebook and Twitter and so on people
post uh violence on there like little
like videos of violence child porn
um some of the darkest things in this
world and to find them at scale is is a
difficult problem
and to act in it aggressively is a
difficult problem but uh that
I think
part of this motivation like saying this
is a big problem we need to take this on
we need to uh find all the darkest
aspects of human nature that rise and
appear on our platform and remove them
so that we can create a place for like
for Humanity to flourish through the
process of conversation but it's just
hard it's just really hard when you look
at like millions of posts trillions of
interactions it's wild what's like the
amount of data but where we are now with
with social media seemed wild and
impossible five years ago right yes I I
actually what frustrates me is I think
they're people who have politicized this
issue in unnecessary ways everyone
regardless of their politics should
support what you just said investing our
money
maybe grants from uh the federal
government in AI skilled people like you
figuring out ways to get violent videos
yeah off of there that that shouldn't be
political
well some of that also requires being
transparent from a social media company
perspective and transparent in a way
that really resists uh being political
to be able to be transparent about your
fight against these
uh evils while still not succumbing to
the sort of the political narratives of
it oh that's tricky but you have to do
that kind of and I think walk calmly
through the fire that's that's what
Twitter feels like if you're being
political is it it's like a firing squad
from every side you know as a leader you
have to kind of walk calmly right and
that is where we need a new generation
of people who will have diverse politics
but will stand up against that right I
mean that's the lesson from after the
Civil War is where progress is made the
war doesn't solve problems of hate where
progress is made is where you have local
leaders and others who stand up and say
we can differ but we're not going we're
going to stop calling people from
certain backgrounds monkeys which was a
common thing to do at that time Jews are
still called monkeys in certain places
right people have to stand up while
still maintaining their political
differences